in 2012 sun yang was on the path of
sporting greatness at the olympics in
london he would become the first Chinese
man ever to win gold in the pool two of
them and followed by another at Rio 2016
but two years on from the Olympics in
Brazil a run-in with drugs testers led
him here the Court of Arbitration for
sport after vials of Suns blood had been
smashed with a hammer
when testers visited him at his home on
Friday the court gave its decision a ban
from swimming for eight years
effectively ending the career of one of
the jewels in the crown of Chinese sport
ready it was not for the athlete to
decide alone that an anti-doping test
shall be invalidated and the sample
containers destroyed as a consequence
Ouyang committed an anti-doping rule
relation by tampering with the doping
control sun's response was immediate
telling China's official news agency
this is unfair I firmly believed in my
innocence I will definitely appeal to
let more people know the truth
the Chinese Swimming Association says it
deeply regrets the ruling and fully
supports son although it had itself
banned him for three months for doping
in 2014 that led to a fracture between
son and many of his rivals Australian
swimmer Mac Horton had branded son a
drug cheat in Rio and in 2019 refused to
share the podium with him at the worlds
in South Korea while the man who was out
shown by son in Rio believes the medals
should be redistributed but this is a
pity you know because a lot of people
sacrificed their whole lives for some
moments you know and it's not just about
me who got silver to him or the guy that
came forth Jimmy gah it's about the guy
that came none I should get my gold
medal back from from Rio and it not for
the moment I lost that I don't really
care about that just for my record you
know more questions remain over this
case son was originally cleared by
Swimming's governing body FINA over the
destroyed samples and it took an appeal
from the world anti-doping agency to
result in Friday's ban as things
standing FINA have not commented on why
they saw things differently polarise al
Jazira